foreign
[Music]
what an amazing story what an incredible
privilege to be a part of that story
[Music]
and we take a look at the story that
never gets old just like its character
Peter Pan one of the most important sort
of points to take away is the importance
of friendship and definitely not taking
your friends for granted never
[Music]
on the big stories and your news too
we want to start with the Comforts in
Sudan which has been making the
headlines a lot we started to
investigate
[Music]
so where is it
well Sudan is a huge country in
Northeast Africa and it shares its
borders with Egypt Libya and Chad
Sudan is a country where the military is
usually in control there's been war and
violence as different leaders fight for
power since it became independent from
the British Empire in 1956.
the latest fighting is between rival
armies over control of the country
the UK government centered military
planes to evacuate British families from
Sudan
these families arrive safely into
Stansted Airport relief is the first
thing and we're out of danger there's no
bombings we're not ducking and Diving
we're home then houses
burnt cards very frightening has changed
many world leaders including the UK
prime minister and the US president have
appealed for both sides to end the
fighting there are fears that
neighboring countries could get involved
in the war to try and end it quickly
because they were allowing Sudan's
natural resources such as the River Nile
oil and gold and there are fares for
Sydney's people
there is a shortage of food warts on
electricity hospitals homes and schools
have been destroyed
nearly a million people mainly women and
children have fled the violence to
neighboring countries
our expert to help us get more info on
this is Kian salakian a senior conflict
and humanitarian advisor for save the
children so what's the latest on the
situation in Sudan so a couple of weeks
ago classes broke out in the capital
city of Sudan in classroom and the
result of that has been really
complicated first of all uh the violence
itself has killed and injured a lot of
people people have been forced to flee
their homes pack up everything that they
can in a few minutes and go cross into
borders but one of the things I think
that we're really starting to see happen
now is the breakdown of things like the
Health Service the education service and
those the implications of that can be
really really long term do you know
anything more about how children and
families are being affected yeah as I
say probably a couple of ways to think
about it the first is those that are
caught up in the fighting itself the
fear the anxiety the uncertainty that
that creates for them and can be really
serious and can have long-term effects
as well on their mental health and their
well-being but then also as I say the
breakdown of services I think it's
something like 60 70 so most of the
Health Service now particularly in
Khartoum isn't working so if you're a
child if you're
um a mother or father worried about your
children's health yeah what do you do
about that so what more needs to be done
to help people there first things first
a kind of a ceasefire some security
within Sudan more support to the
communities that are going to be there
in the long term but then also for those
that have been displaced making sure
that they have the support that they
require yeah well it's terrible and I
really hope that the situation can get
better so thank you so much for speaking
to us thank you
of course there's another big conflict
is the Russian invasion of Ukraine
this figure is released by the Russian
authorities claiming it shows a drone
attack on President Putin's home in the
Kremlin in the capital of Moscow Russia
has accused the Ukraine of trying to
attack the president but how do we know
if this is fake or fact but we just
don't
this video is released by the Russian
authorities so we can't check if it's
for real
and the Ukrainian government released a
statement saying they had nothing to do
with the alleged drone attack
so because of the king's coronation a
lot of real news and facts have been
doing their rounds on social media
here's one that could be fake or fact
we all know the late Queen Elizabeth
loved animals she kept horses racing
pigeons and of course her famous corgis
starting with her first dog Sue at the
age of 18. throughout her lifetime the
queen owned over 30 Pembroke share
corgis but did the queen actually invent
a new dog breed fake or fat we'll find
out later
foreign
video of a recent visit to Birmingham by
Prince William he answered the phone and
took a reservation at an Indian
restaurant the customer had no idea it
was Prince William they were speaking
do we have a season two to find out
right now
as well as taking a booking The Prince
and Princess of Wales helped out
comparing dishes in the kitchen I wonder
if they do that in the palace
questions
so it's been reported that the
coronation cost the UK government a lot
of money to Stage well a lot of Irwin
and security to make sure that everyone
was safe and they'll also cost for
decorating things like streets the
buildings and of course the ceremony
itself but some people on social media
are asking if the expense was right
especially when so many families are
struggling to pay the bills as the cost
of everyday needs like food and
electricity become more expensive
but other people say that the coronation
is an important tradition that attracts
a lot of Tourism which brings more money
into the country well time to get your
shot on this we headed to Eleanor Palmer
Primary School in Camden seeing what
they had to say about the coronation
it's quite an important event so
somewhere high up set around 75 million
100 million yeah yeah for about like 50
75 15 minutes yeah
[Music]
whoa that was 100 million pounds
that is like a lot of money 100 million
that's that's a lot yeah you're going
all right how I guess
but like actually how can it cost that
much it makes sense it's a very very
nice special occasion where you know
King Charles will be crowned King it is
for a coronation that doesn't happen
much and also like billions of people
are going to be watching it yeah so much
it should be special that's far too much
like there's a lot of problems in the UK
and they could use that kind of money to
help them but no you're gonna spend it
on a coronation I think like it doesn't
happen very often and it's a really big
thing and everyone wants to come but
most of the money could be used on the
environment yeah they could portion it
up the nurses that are on strike and the
situation in Ukraine could also be aided
by that well if they decided to cut back
the amount of money to like let's say 10
million what would you choose to spend
the money on there's all these people
striking because they don't have a high
enough pay that money could just go to
them
I don't think it is worth it I get he
has to have his moment everyone else has
but there's not much happiness of
sitting in front of a TV for ages just
waiting for a crown to go on someone's
head
if you have a story and want to report
on FYI get in touch via our webpage or
even better get your teacher to set up
an FYI News Club at your school members
get the chance to report for us we'll
even help you film Your Own Story you
can watch and discuss the latest
episodes with free resources every week
[Music]
so you may have seen that King Charles
was crowned on a Golden Throne during
the coronation but did you know that the
throne is actually covered in graffiti
[Music]
a lot of which was done by Westminster
School pupils and visitors to The Abbey
hundreds of years ago in the 18th and
19th centuries
[Music]
this is wrexham football club
celebrating getting promoted to the
football league for the first time in 15
years
rexham FC in Wales is one of the world's
oldest football clubs but after loads of
success they fill in hard times and then
end up dropping out of the football
league but in 2020 they were bizarrely
bought by two Hollywood actors Ryan
Reynolds and Ron mcelhenney since then
they have been going to strength to
strength just like a Hollywood movie and
the most recent win against borehamwood
means that they're back in the football
league I can't believe
that I'm in a place in my life where any
sports team let alone when I happen to
somehow be a co-chairman of
um has affected me this deeply like I
feel like there was a DNA change when um
when we we lived through that
borehamwood moment so what's next for
wrexham Football Club
put a hold of super fun Dylan to find
out more hi Dylan thanks so much for
joining us so this is a massive win for
wrexham football club and the women's
team have also been promoted from their
league so what's it like being a wrexham
fan right now absolutely massive
everyone in the town's loving it uh so
much more attendance to Home and Away
the following brilliant atmospheres in
the grounds amazing commercial or
anything more so so is it safe to say
that Robin Ryan are hit notches for
football fans but with wrexham as a city
why are they so popular lovely nice nice
people caring what they've done this
time they've helped us bring it back and
get us in the place we belong so what's
next for wrexham football club and how
far do you think this can now go oh
promotion get back to where you belong
establish myself in this league and hope
to get promoted so Dylan I know you went
to the parade what was it like well 20
000 people 15 20 000 people came
celebrate the men's and women's team and
their success off the club
just a great atmosphere finish the
season well thanks so much for speaking
to us bye bye
bye all fake news that the queen created
a new breed of dog
well it's a fact
the doggy is a mix of a Dachshund and a
corgi and the queen earned over 10 of
them during her lifetime including her
last dog candy
Peter Pan and his friend Tinkerbell are
back taking three children from London
on an epic adventure
to a land where they'll never have to
grow up
I think that's a bug
Peter Pan were you expecting someone
else what do you think young people can
learn from this film one of the most
important sort of points to take away is
the importance of friendship and
definitely not taking your friends for
granted never
lie away from how scary it seems
I don't want to grow up
want things to say the way they are
growing up is the biggest adventure of
all and for young people not to be
scared to take on the responsibilities
that come with growing up no rules no
schools no bedtimes and most of all no
growing up growing up doesn't mean that
you have to lose what you loved about
your childhood just because you're
technically an age doesn't mean you have
to lose your curiosity your joy Your
Love of Adventure I don't know every day
you're just hitting a different balance
of adults and kid I haven't grown up in
many ways I think you know one of the
important aspects of acting to me is is
being playful
um using my imagination as much as
possible and so
that that's probably both been
frustrating for those around me and for
myself but also very very rewarding yeah
Peter Pan started life in a book by the
Scottish novelist J.M Barry more than a
hundred years ago but the story has
never got old
David what was your inspiration behind
creating a new version of this peated
pantale for this generation did you feel
it needed updating I love the 2003
version that was a really meaningful
film to me when I was younger but I felt
that here in 2023 we could really
introduce this story to an entirely New
Generation with a different perspective
Captain it's Peter
never say
his name so Jude what made you want to
play the character of Captain Hook the
opportunity of learning to sword fight
and to macaron on a pirate ship
stand on top of gigantic crocodiles and
I mean all of that sort of stuff is
playful and fun and an extraordinary
sort of place to be really just like old
times all your times are old captain now
I have to ask what was it like filming
the flying scenes because it looked
incredible so much effort goes into each
scene you have to work on the taking off
the flying itself and then the landing
but it was so much fun
foreign
[Music]
the coronation isn't the only big event
happening in the UK this month the
Eurovision song contest is coming to
Liverpool last year's winners were
Ukraine but because of the war second
place UK offered to host a song contest
Liverpool hasn't braced the Ukrainian
culture giving refugees living care a
big welcome we're going to leave you
with some messages from British
Ukrainian children who'll be supporting
both the UK and Ukraine this Eurovision
bye
as an English Ukrainian I'm proud that
we can help host Eurovision and help
show our solidarity to Ukraine I
wouldn't Ukraine but I live in England
so both of the countries I'd be
absolutely happy with it it's nice that
a country that has offered so much help
to Ukraine during this war is able to
take over such an important thing for
them we are waiting for the euro vision
to start thank you England come on
England come on Ukraine thank you so
much England for all the support and the
hospitality I can't wait until the show
to happen
that I died
[Music]